it is great to be joined today by Andy
yen who's the co-founder of the
end-to-end encrypted email service
protonmail which was founded in 2014 I
know a lot of people in our audience
Andy have over the last six to twelve
months started using protonmail accounts
I know I made one a couple of months ago
and and do use it now so let's maybe
just to start with what what do we mean
when we say encrypted email and I guess
importantly what happens if your email
is not encrypted what are the
implications what's the alternative to
encrypted email well the main idea
behind encrypted email is to build an
email service we're actually only you
and the recipient have the ability to
read your emails
so that means nobody else not the
internet provider and not even us have
the ability to read your emails this is
good for a couple reasons first is
because we don't have access to your
emails we can never beat your privacy
and also if TomTom Bell award you
somehow become breached or hacked in
factory emails are still secure so it's
sort of the you know next step forward
in email security so when we talk about
you know our audience has been following
NSA surveillance hacks and breaches that
have taken place on all sorts of
different platforms if you let's first
talk about the possibility of backdoors
that that can be built into different
communication systems whether it's email
or social media platforms by virtue of
how protonmail
is set up is it even possible that there
could be a so-called backdoor set up
well if you were to compared to say a
service like you know Gmail the NSA
actually doesn't need a backdoor to get
access to that right they simply ask
Google to you know give them that
information so you know in fact it's
very easy to you know get access if they
wanted to to Gmail account data you know
with protonmail it's a bit different
because it's encrypted in a way that we
cannot decrypt so in fact it's not
possible for any third party to come to
us and say you know give us information
on this user because we actually cannot
do that so this is why you know it's
it's a bit of a struggle guarantee of
having your privacy and security are
respected you know there are ways of
course to our backdoor encryption you
know you can be you know if you were
somehow forced to do that you know is it
possible for us to somehow break protons
encryption you know that of course is
possible right because there's no such
thing that is a hundred percent secure
every system can be breached in one way
or another but in protons case it's
let's say you know severely harder and
who that jurisdiction being in
Switzerland you know it's actually not
legal to you know do any sort of
encryption backdoors without user
consent if police were investigating a
crime and the suspects it was learned
communicated via protonmail is there
anything that authorities could do
technologically to obtain those
communications and then also legally in
order to obtain those communications
well from from a tech perspective all
the encryption is happening on client
devices so you know because of that
there's actually no way to really you
know force us to decrypt it because we
don't have the ability to do that right
so technically it's not really possible
now if the authorities were to you know
identify the suspect get a hold of the
suspect then they can of course compel
the suspect to enter the password and
get it and get it that way and that's
actually the you know I would say the
correct way because you know typically
in mass surveillance assumes everybody
is guilty but the proper way to do this
is to really go after the targeted cases
that you want to go after and that's
fine you know not going after service
providers but it's it or and after the
criminals themselves so you know um you
know using proton oil doesn't mean that
you can conduct you know criminal
activity of impunity if you get caught
the police can still look at your device
and you know ask you to give them the
password yet there's this I want to talk
about that idea of committing crimes
with impunity that you mentioned you
know in in the cryptocurrency space
there was this assumption made by some
early in the Bitcoin days that Bitcoin
was being used significantly for illegal
transactions whether it's drug deals or
even worse than
and then when the Silk Road got shut
down it barely had any impact on the
sort of amount of Bitcoin of money that
was flowing through Bitcoin at the time
Bitcoin was much smaller and that sort
of started making people think oh wait a
second one of the main sort of purveyors
of these illegal purchases and sales was
shut down and it barely had any impact
on on Bitcoin usage we were wrong about
the propensity for using it using it for
criminal activity how do you approach
the idea that since if you're not doing
anything wrong you shouldn't really be
worried anyway about this stuff that
protonmail
is disproportionately used for criminal
activity well I think there's the
headlines and there's the reality right
and there's often a very very big
difference between that so in the
Bitcoin case you know it was interesting
new technology so the headlines of you
know big coin is primarily being used
with illegal transactions well as in
many ways a sexy headline but that
doesn't really reflect well with the
actual reality right and it's the same
photo mill you know we have statistics
about the number of police requests that
we get first is the overall user base
and in fact you know Yahoo Google and
other big tech companies also release
these figures and that you know our rate
of criminal use on our platform is not
you know from us it's not actually any
different from say Google Yahoo these
are providers so if you look at the pure
data and impaired facts there's nothing
to support the you know assertion that
in fact these platforms are used more by
criminals
this is just you know isn't borne out by
the evidence when people say that line
who worries why worry about who has your
data if you're not doing anything wrong
what is your as a privacy advocate
what's your best argument against that
well it's kind of a you know stupid kind
of you know way to think about things
right because you know if you're not
concerned about people looking at your
stuff then you know you what do you need
a password in the first place right why
do you need locks in your dorms or
curtains on your windows I think you
know generally speaking everybody needs
and deserves a certain level of privacy
and this is something that's a mate you
know being human right so you know
people that say to me hey you know I'm
nothing to hide I don't really care if
you ask them you know give me your email
password they're gonna say no so you
know what I think when people say that
they don't actually mean it do you think
that there's something about if if a
random person asks you so to draw a
distinction unless I this is interesting
if someone comes up to you and says I'd
like your email password you say no
because they're not really involved in
any way with you and your email service
I guess where people might differ and
this is not my view but I'm playing
devil's advocate here somebody could say
well if whoever Gmail or whoever it is
is sort of the provider of that service
then it's sort of a different
relationship it's not a random person
asking for your password it's the the
people who are sort of running the
server I mean it's it feels even silly
to be saying it because because it's not
a good reason for them to have access to
your email but there is a different
relationship between a random person on
the street asking for your house keys or
your password and Gmail having some way
of accessing your email even though I
wouldn't defend it but it's not the same
relationship yeah it's not exactly the
same but you know the risks kind of are
the same and I would actually argue that
the risk is that you magnified right
example this is actually Facebook with
the whole scandal with Cambridge
analytic ah right you know Facebook has
an immense amount of data about every
citizen in the world Google does as well
but I would say to even a larger extent
and you know this information can be
used for example for you know political
campaigns they can be use for all sorts
of reasons right it creates kind of a
very very no profile of each user that's
available to governments or whoever
wants to get access to them so you know
the bigger argument here is that you
know concentrating all personal data in
certain places like Google or Facebook
in a way that you know is accessible by
third parties is actually kind interest
or support you know society as a whole
you also see this you know just from
looking for example at China right China
is a company where all the tech
companies in fact
how to give access to the government and
the end result is you have a society
where you know it's basically a massive
surveillance state that is powered by
big tech now you know I would argue that
the US and Western Europe is not you
know in that same level yet but in fact
the tenet book
capability is to do that you know exists
because this data is also concentrated
in the same way nd it sort of sounds
like it's not necessarily that the
people who run the email service reading
your email is the the worst possible
problem it's that it's sort of a
characteristic of a type of society that
is more authoritarian for example so
when we talk about like Trump's attacks
on the media it's not that he's
personally going to start jailing
journalists although maybe he would want
to I don't know but it's that the
attacks on media by government are
emblematic or a characteristic of
authoritarian type governments that do a
lot worse things as well that's yeah if
something how to put it the way you
would put it is essentially you know
when you have you know when you don't
use encryption when you have big tech
cracking data for the purposes of
serving your ads you basically have put
together the infrastructure that would
enable a society like no China to arise
you know here in the West right and the
student danger to have that
infrastructure you know out there
because if it's not abused today there's
no sign that it won't be abused in the
future and that's exactly the risk that
we face right I think when people sign
up for Facebook ten years ago they
probably weren't aware that one day this
might be used by political campaigns
right that's not a risk that you
realized and get it happened so that's
really the danger here is that we cannot
predict you know all the possible
negative side effects that could come
from this and you know that's why it's
probably better to you know how privacy
as a default online target Turkish
president err Diwan I think it was a
year or two ago said something along the
lines of I'm more against the internet
every day and over the summer Turkey
actually banned
male are there other countries that have
done this or that you think are or have
knowledge are considering banning
protonmail well you know I think in any
country that has a government that is
you know very authoritative which is you
know trying to control the population
you know the first thing they need to
remove is actually a free press right
and if you want to take away freedom of
speech best way to do it is to go after
privacy so fashion all these countries
you first see privacy services getting
you know taken down because that's kind
of the first step to limit freedom of
speech and that's how you control a
society so protonmail and Turkey that
was you know one incident another
incident was telegram in Russia this is
the part that you see over and over
again so I would say any country for
those governments that you know are not
democratic you'll see this pattern
emerging more and more I think in the
next couple years do you tend to see
protonmail be of more interest to
libertarian minded folks people on the
political right people on the political
left is it sort of a political in terms
of who protonmail
appears to appeal to in the United
States I think it's very apolitical
because privacy is something that
appeals to I think everybody right you
know this is something that crosses
nationality it crosses gender it also
crosses political leanings to kind of
give an example you know before you know
the the election in 2016 in the US a lot
of users were Republicans who are afraid
of you know Obama NSA surveillance right
and then after the election it was
liberals afraid of you know Trump NSA
surveillance you know that kind of show
is that you know it's something that I
think people whether you're on the left
or the right is something that is needed
so it's really kind of a universal value
how frequently do regulators of
different kinds get in touch with you
because they either are concerned about
the the service that you're providing
that they don't like it do you ever see
attempts at sort of bullying you into
doing something what are your sort of
interactions with regulatory agencies
that's an interesting question because
it's changed a lot in the past four
years right in the early days people
didn't really understand it
um regulators were concerned they
thought it was you know helping to aid
criminals so early days there's quite a
bit of pushback then I would say around
you know two or three years ago that
really started a shift especially about
two years ago and now regulators are
much more understanding and what has
really changed in the past four years is
a rise of cybercrime right
in 2014 it wasn't quite the same
situation as it is today who are
preachers are much more common they're
much more damaging and the economic
impacts are much higher so you know
people are not so hung up about privacy
anymore they're they care more about
security and in fact what protonmail
provides in addition to privacy is very
very good security so I think what has
changed is the security arguments
becoming more and more relevant as
Internet gets more and more dangerous
and this is also led to more
understanding from regulators about the
need for encryption and supporting
services like from Tamil as I mentioned
I've been using a protonmail account for
a little while now and people there are
people who want to send me information
possible story leads who say I don't
want to use any other email service
other than protonmail to send it to you
so it's very interesting that this is a
much bigger part of the conversation now
that than it ever was even as someone
working in journalism we've been
speaking with Andy Yin he's the
co-founder of the end-to-end encrypted
email service protonmail which has been
around since 2014 Andy thank you so much
for talking to us today
yes thank you for having me